how's it going bros my name is peter pan
before this video begins i have an
important announcement pewdiepie legend
of the brofist it's finally coming out
on Steam finally you bros can play this
on your computers but even better grab
your bro because co-op is gonna be
available in this game it's coming out
December 10 so you know what you're
gonna do during Christmas so don't miss
that and enjoy the video
hey let's go boy bye here welcome to
just cost 3 oh that's [ __ ] cool it
just starts like that look at that [ __ ]
man this game is so much fun oh no I my
car fill up the clip no big deal
no no honestly like you travel faster
with a [ __ ] parachute than the car so
what's the [ __ ] point all right so
our objective now is to take over this
the city right here we built this city
they built this city and explosions ah
no [ __ ] were given hey how [ __ ] dare
you violate and an innocent lamppost
like that
come back here [ __ ] where you going
man come back this is my favorite
feature in any video game ever
alright now apologize to mr. Lampe
you're riding there alright mate have a
good one sign our mother what what
happened I'm back oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
are you doing don't fight back there you
go Vick oh and she was never had fun
okay it's so hard to like stay on track
what the [ __ ] you're doing in this game
I will liberate you from this this town
you're free a man never wanted to be a
chair you're welcome
we need to blow this the [ __ ] up how do
we do that I don't really know what I'm
doing you what if we just try and pull
it down
huh guess it's more complicated let's
try a human suspects no need something
stronger a and one guy I don't
understand okay we have explosives there
we go yeah [ __ ] that's right
you're coming with me now no only the
head
let's bring the head as a souvenir oh
the music is so relaxing alright let's
find some more [ __ ] how you doing mate
Jesus oh [ __ ] me oh uh what do I do
sorry it's mine now yeah ah ah so good
such a good pilot - don't worry innocent
people I will save you I will save you
from the bad people oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god run run run run run
run Jesus Christ this is Christ oops my
bad you know what that one was on me
[ __ ] me how am I gonna cross it's our
boat I can steal yep there we go hey
[ __ ]
come back here that's right [ __ ] [ __ ]
you
we're going for the mountain
[ __ ] yeah oh hello hello hello I just
found a shortcut huh ah I'm fine don't
worry about me guys don't worry about me
one second well this is a little faster
than a train I hate what what haha I'm
fine
[ __ ] you train what a dick ass train
what the [ __ ] am I gonna have to climb
that thing myself there's my ride get
off me
there we go to the mansion baby haha Shh
Terrace haha what is that
is that a [ __ ] moose hey Mei how you
doing man hey I said out of the [ __ ] are
you doing I probably should stop doing
that oh no oh no oh no
don't worry mate I'll make sure you go I
would style baby be free
that wait damn it oops suck-up
sorry
all right wearing moose land now oh look
at this [ __ ] okay there's this mine
small step repairs and a pair two pair
for a pet whoa
alright the world record is 14 seconds
I'm pretty sure we're gonna be in it oh
yeah
lie on the wings of love oh my god so
[ __ ] awesome okay it seems like
everyone try to do what I did
[ __ ] hell oh look a llama look hey
where you going llama let's try you
[ __ ] you're my new best friend
Larry the llama oh [ __ ] sake guys I'm
trying to teach Larry the llama lesson
here whoa
the [ __ ] is this oh yeah
well what the hell is that car get me
and get me and get me an I gotta go I
gotta go to bed again guys I gotta go
get it again again I gonna get a
comeback one don't I don't I don't 99.9
tonight
come on [ __ ] ah
we're fine we made it Oh God nevermind
oh they're really nice one guys
oh [ __ ] let's be a squirrel ah alright
where you guys keeping the cool air
ships in here F [ __ ] you trying to hide
them from me
I'm assuming these are unlocked well
they are now scuse me screw said to me
and it's time for liftoff baby liftoff
they're an S word boo boo wow wow Jesus
half-half we're back we're back huh for
fun your friend stabilized stabilized
stabilized stabilized
that's how it's done
well hello there okay all right I'm
gonna take a break there this game is so
much fun I love playing this game I
might throw it it's a little data so I'm
gonna yep
all right I'll see you bros the next one
say awesome whee
good thing I'm an excellent driver not a
problem
all right gonna edit that out